So, you might be wondering why
do I need a master resume?
Let me tell you about how it helped
me during my own job search.
As I happened to be a person
with many different interests,
I have worked in many different fields
and positions from media to epidemics,
publishing non-profits,
technology startups, and as a performer.
Before moving to the US,
I had over 14 years of professional
experience under my belt.
Many of these experiences are very
interesting to talk about, like being
a producer of a daily talk show with
lots and lots of paternity testing, but
completely irrelevant to a career I
wanted to pursue in a new continent.
Right before I started at Udacity,
I worked for a cultural institution of
the Federal Republic of Germany,
who wanted to have all the dates and
names of everyone I ever worked with and
every training I've ever taken.
It's rare that anyone besides
the government will want to know this
much about you.
In fact, a guiding rule of thumb in this
lesson is to keep resumes to one page if
at all possible but what I submitted to
this institution wasn't a normal resume,
it's what I later called
my master resume,
a seven page tome of
all of my experiences.
What was really helpful,
is that as long as I kept my master
resume up to date, I could use it as
a data source to populate any kind of
one page resume I wanted to write and
as a project manager I often needed to
tweak my resumes depending on the job.
For example, when applying to Udacity,
I was able to pull out
all of my education experience as well
as my experiences managing products of
international scale and
technology companies.
It's that kind of targeting
that gets you an interview.